all I have for you is a word
Tennant it'll open the right doors some
of the wrong ones to use it carefully to
do what I do I need some idea of the
threat we face as I understand it we're
trying to prevent World War 3 I must say
and I'm again here something was like a
do you have an interest in a certain
Russian national
my spring man
one enough
you can communicate with the future
time travel no inversion a mitten poetry
you know shooting the bullet you're
catching it
what I've seen too much my try and
keeper
and duty transcends national interests
this is about survival
seems bold old I'm fine with that
thought you were gonna say nuts
this is where our worlds collide
how would you like to die oh you chose
the wrong profession
[Music]
I know that from here
hasn't happened yet
there are people in the future who need
us
I need tenant
we need to save them here and now
it's reversing the flow of time wasn't
us being here now I mean it never
happened
you want to crash a plane but not from
the air no such matter well how big a
plane that part is a little dramatic
you
you